we might be drunk we
might be drunk as long as we
are hanging out you know we might be
drunk
raise a glass let's talk [ __ ] head peeps
wrecks and a bit
maybe drunk we might be
drunk yeah
hey hey folks here we are we might be
drunk
we're here we got a whole different
setup some nice digs
i like it a nice drink i like that we
when we were doing the zoom ones we were
doing different drinks and that was fun
but this is
it's something about doing the same
drink yes we're on the same page
here we go clink it up we got a nice
anejo this was a gift from my pal jamie
lynn oh she's the best yeah
i would never buy this this is like you
know top shelf stuff
it's good stuff man look at that i'm a
clear tequila guy but this
is so smooth and yejo is i don't know a
lot about tequila but that's what that's
the tequila snobs love the anejo that's
what they always owe to order
ah well what the hell's a mezcal i i
okay i don't see i'm the wrong guy to
ask i think yeah i think like a
is it a mezcal or tequila can be a
mezcal but a mezcal
something weird i'm totally off here
it's tough it's like i don't even know
why i started that sentence now
i'm like i should just shut the [ __ ] up
well it's like when you call a cuban a
mexican people like what are you crazy
they're totally different i'm like oh
are they
yeah i was just in miami so i i did that
on accident oh yeah
they got ugly don't do that yeah i'll
never do that at a cockfight again
if you're in miami you just got to go
cuban every time yeah
like new york puerto rican yeah good
point
good point that's that's the guess the
dominicans are mixed in and then you get
a guatemalan and venezuelan every now
and then it's tough
i was getting some threatening messages
i did a joke and
i got this about where i say dating me
is kind of like it's like going to the
dominican republic
uh you know it's like like you're like
oh this is great for like five days but
after that you're like this has some
problems i'm not aware of
and i and every once in a while i'll get
shared and i'll get like another message
someone like i'm dominican and if i see
you i'm gonna kick your [ __ ] ass
yeah damn and i'm just like the joke is
about
people being stupid and not knowing that
their vacation spots have
problems and then i'm [ __ ]
it's kind of the reverse thing when
you're [ __ ] on a city like you're
like [ __ ] cleveland huh somebody goes
woo
i love cleveland like no i was [ __ ]
on it
they just hear their town and they go
crazy by the way dominicans what
they have an n-word pass do they i mean
i don't know what i've heard i think it
varies uh
you know white people are always like oh
you're stealing black culture which is
true but
so are they i mean do they have a pass
i think so i mean go up to go up to
washington heights
it's uh it's said quite liberally
i'm just saying i don't know the rules
now the asian kids are saying it who
knows that's
definitely not that's definitely not
flying i don't think maybe that's where
all the
the hate's coming from i don't know
i've seen the videos
yeah this is good stuff though i like it
tequila because
is it an upper they say it's like the
only say it's the only but i never
get like i get like a temporary boost
yeah that's true
that's a good point that is the first
thing that the tequila guy's like you
know it's the only upper and you're like
all right i've heard that six times why
are you doing cocaine as well
right right but bert crusher said go
clear
tequila vodka gin less hangover yeah so
that's how i got into it now i'm hooked
but this is a nejo is hitting the spot
it's with go clear is what they say when
you join scientology also right
yeah that's got a hangover though that
sticks with you
either way either way you've told people
too much right
right is it true that a scientologist
they know they tell you all your secrets
and then they just got you for life
that's the rumor that's yeah that's what
i hear i think that's why they still ha
i would assume that's how they still
have tom cruise and travolta
yes you pay a ton of money you tell them
all you're like molested i got diddled i
[ __ ] my sister whatever it is and then
now you can't get it
like and seen we got it yeah yeah
yeah you're [ __ ] yeah that's uh it's
weird
if travolta is the other thing is that
he's gay and if he is gay
i mean he was married to kelly preston
who i thought was one of the hottest so
this is so hot
oh my god yeah yeah it must be crazy to
be married to someone that hot and not
even enjoy it
i know right it's like uh you know
you're you work in a butcher shop you
got all these cuts of meat and you're a
vegan
that's got to be tough they must have
[ __ ] though because they have kids
yeah no i mean who knows maybe he's bi
maybe
i don't know maybe after a while you you
know it's almost like an epstein thing
where you're like i gotta
i gotta go something new i gotta mix it
up here i've had the best
is that did epstein mix it up well i
think it's at first you're banging
models and then you're like
all right i've conquered that mountain
now we gotta go younger
and then i think you can hook that's
what i assume it's like booze you just
get sick of it
yeah then you go to coke it's a gateway
veg yeah
i've had 18 years let me try something a
little newer
right right yes exactly tastes like a
ninth grader what was your joke about
what was your joke about grape juice
oh yeah joke about that it was like uh
when i was a kid i liked grape juice now
as an adult i like red wine
and when i was a kid i liked when i was
15 i like 15 year olds
now i like adult women
but i still like grape juice so it was
it was saying how scary it is that your
brain knows i love it
to not [ __ ] kids but it also still likes
grape juice i remember the first time i
heard that joke
i was downstairs the seller and i was
watching it with nikki glazer and
we both turned to each other and we both
went great joke wow it's fun when you
watch another comic and two comics are
both like smiling like
yes wow see that makes me feel better
because that
joke bombed for like a month and then
you told me you liked it and i kept
doing it
only because of that interesting well
people hear the pedo stuff and they just
kind of pull back but i needed another
comment to go no no no
[ __ ] those [ __ ] keep going it's weird
to work out
a joke with a little bite on it because
the second you get pushback sometimes
you're like
oh i'm not only a bad comedian i'm an
[ __ ] exactly
exactly that's why i think edgy or
whatever you want to call it dicey
material
is so fun to hear because you're like
wow he made it work he figu
the writing was good enough that he got
through that because even an
observational clean joke
is is rocky in the beginning you know so
let alone
some pedo or anal or whatever it is
funny to say oh like pedo i think vegito
is a funny like on peep show what they
said pedo
it almost sounds nice pito louie had
this great bit about like
like if you [ __ ] a 15 year old and you
[ __ ] a two-year-old
there's gotta be a different word like
that's kind of shitty that
you know this guy [ __ ] a girl in his
neighborhood who like wanted to have sex
sure she was it was illegal but this
guy's [ __ ] a baby they're not they're
the same thing that's we gotta we gotta
get some degrees damn that's [ __ ]
good that's dark
dark as hell but it's funny but it goes
to that patrice point of like
you gotta let us try everything you
gotta let us play you know
yeah cause it's not all ready to go out
of the gate
that's the good thing though is like
when you go that hard sometimes they'll
be like all right i mean
they can tell sometimes when you almost
worsen going really hard is going like
not quite hard enough yes
and then they're just like is he not
kidding yes exactly you gotta lean in
all the way
it's a stand-up show we're always
kidding but yeah of course
but yeah sometimes you don't go hard
you some like that's the good thing
about jezelnik you go so [ __ ] hard
right and then they go okay this is
obviously a joke this is like ridiculous
but if you if you pull back a little
then they're like
uh it could be serious yeah you're right
you were
in miami on sunday were we were either
all weekend all weekend the friday
saturday sunday gig
miami improv oh yeah beautiful club
amazing staff
great great uh great weekend great night
damn that's like a classic man miami is
a city i've never done stand up because
it's not a great comedy town but this
club pulls it off i mean
it's cocaine and fake tits and twerking
and beach you know it has they don't
want to hear our thoughts on you know
anxiety that's so true
they really don't like dave mattel won't
work there he's like [ __ ] miami i skip
it
he did an insomniac episode back in the
day there was pretty funny yeah i could
see him hating miami dude
oh he hates it because he's like a
little troll you know he doesn't want to
go there and he's wearing like all black
and you know
boots and a hoodie and a car heart
jacket he can't go in the sun
funny i posted a picture today and uh in
my head i'm like this is like a cool pi
shot you know it's like a tour poster
and uh
i was like make it look like the maltese
falcon alternate poster to this guy
comedy artwork guy and like three of the
comments are like why does he look like
nosferatu
[ __ ] it's because i'm so pale and i'm
wearing a trench coat ah that's pretty
good that's pretty
pretty good i tell once said to me on
stage you go sam you're a vampire
what do you think he's so good he gets
you on the way to getting you i know
i know he told my friend uh sean murphy
he's like this tall lamp i just did a
show
yeah great guy funny guy check him out
he said
you look like a butler at a haunted
house
and you're like oh that's so perfect
that's like poetic a butler in a haunted
house
i mean butler's funny haunted house is
funny and he combined it i mean that he
goes to some
deep part of his brain that we haven't
touched yet yeah
it's pretty amazing it's pretty good god
damn miami though
what were some highlights well i brought
the lady we did south beach which is
just like bananas there's no covet down
there
uh everybody had butt implants it was
crazy
yeah it was fun to watch because you
know they're all in bikinis you could
just stare
and uh i took photos and all that but
like it was just
just so miami you know when you go to a
place and like this is exactly what i
was hoping it would be
and more it was that butt implants oh
is that safe i don't know i i mean i
just read about someone who died from
butt implants so they can't be that safe
well it's like johnson and johnson
you lose a few but uh you know you keep
going
oh man but yeah great great town and
south beaches
it was very poppin yeah you know like i
know they you know you know they just
had a spring break they had to like
shut the city down it wasn't even
because of cove but it was just like the
spring break got too
crazy yeah damn butt implants
i know it's weird to sit on your
implants isn't that odd
i have a joke book in my back pocket
that throws me off i can't imagine i
can't imagine having fake
i know fake ass i also think about like
man sometimes they'll see a porn star
with like a giant fake ass and fake tits
and they're ripped i'm like how do you
work out
right i know yeah there's a there's an
mma
lady with fake tits and i'm like doesn't
that get in the way
and what if somebody hits that it pops
now we got that whole thing
damn yeah it's tough out there but uh
the the women
like i was with my girl it's just so
hard because all the women look like
cartoon characters like jessica rabbit
with the tiny waist and the huge hips
and the fake ass
and the big jugs it's like i gotta look
yeah
you look like lois in the family guy
porn that you see on the internet where
you're like
holy [ __ ] i jerked off like a marge
simpson version of this this is crazy i
thought i was the only one who jerked
after this
what is though what is who does that
they're fun that's weird
yeah it's definitely where there's a
seinfeld parody there's like a big bang
theory there's
there's all of it it's weird to jerk off
to stuff you like
like i like to keep it's like separation
at church and state yeah let's
keep let's keep my shows out of my porn
yeah
yeah i know i'm guilty of it
because we've we've all had the thought
like oh elaine or whatever what if
cramer was plowing a lane you know
and then they just they do it for you
the imagination is gone
frasier porn yeah oh man niles
huge nails getting pegged oh god
i got pegged by ross and the dads in the
bark alarms like here we go again
underrated show great writing uh
what wait [ __ ] i had a thing on porn i
wanted to bring up when i lost it
hit me i'm all i'm all foggy from the
weekend just
tons of booze in miami and then sun all
day
it's tough cause you got the lady there
so you want to show her a good time
so usually we like to rest during the
day then bring it at night with the
shows
i had to bring it all day and at night
oh god it must be so i'd never
bring someone on the road that must be
so tough toad i really value my uh
i'm gonna do nothing time that's the
thing it's my escape
and like and then i look at my tour
schedule i'm like do i need to be
escaping this month yeah
yeah i'm escaping a lot right right i
know but i do like it
i like it i love it i avoid i avoid
anything because
there's you can just get out of any
commitment come to my wedding i'm on
tour
i'm on the road i'm working i need money
yeah yeah it's so true but
your the girlfriends they uh they see oh
miami oh uh san francisco oh these are
fun town i'm
coming and i'm like all right she ain't
coming with you to dayton ohio
no god no i don't even want to go there
but
then she does the uh wait what time is
the show seven o'clock
oh then when are you done well there's
two shows two shows like
get out of here sister this is how it
goes does she ever just stay in the
hotel while you do the shows
sometimes but she gets bored she's very
extroverted whereas i'm very introverted
so we're getting
yeah yeah but she's like i'll just go
and i'm like all right but i don't want
to hear any pouting in the green room
because i'm like i gotta go sell shirts
she's like you're selling shirts i'm
like get out of here this is how it goes
what shirts we gotta get shirts for this
part oh that's a good call
we gotta think of something cool yeah by
the way i know i i
looked at comments for like the first
[ __ ] egg forever because of mark
cause i wanted to see what you guys
thought of the new theme song
i saw some love i saw some hate i don't
know
i like it what do you think i like it
too but people hate change you know
we talked people were hating on you
people were hating on the other day they
were hating on the old ones so
i say you give them a month with it and
then we'll see if they still hate it
we'll reevaluate it
yes dude but we got that's the great
colin smith who did both of those songs
he can he can shift his voice he's
incredible
he's really good i sent him a nice
message he was he was very thankful
great guy
great guy great talent uh one time i saw
him make out with a celebrity i'm not
gonna say it oh same i know
oh i think he did more than make out
with her if you know what i mean
well done kathy bates
[Laughter]
still got it up black chick right
no i'm giving them clues i don't want to
give it away i'm just curious if it's
the same celebrity
who knows oh boy who knows maybe
dominican he's a cocksman hard to tell
um hmm damn i had a porn point and i
lost it
yeah what was your what was your early
porn stuff were you a cause
i think i was mill from the gecko oh wow
and and
i think we've talked about this but i'm
not as into milfs as i used to be
because i'm getting older yeah they're
peers
and now it's like she's like just four
years older than me yeah it's like all
right
yeah it's not that exciting but i still
am attracted to older women i think oh
same
same well older women are fun because uh
not only are they a little experienced
and a little weathered you know they got
some crow's feet
maybe a sag here and there i don't want
to say
but they're not they're almost like
dudes where they're like i just gotta
get laid and get out of here
you know there's no like what are we
well there's there's
two there's that but there's also the
like
i'm mad i'm not married right now oh and
i'm kind of like
you thought i was the guy ah right right
i told you i'm going on tour for the
whole you know yeah no
no well that's why divorcees the best
because they're a little more realistic
they're like i've done it once
he hit me in the face with a you know a
golf club i'm out
i just want to get laid you banged elon
tiger but uh yeah i just want to like
you know
get laid every now and then have a
cocktail at a piano bar
and you know tend to my uh malamute
i really just like to be it's tough i
i have here's this problem i i keep
people around
but then i also don't want them there oh
you ever do that
so you're like i don't want silence yes
but i also
need to not be talking to you right now
it's it's very hard for me like
yeah i know i like i'm not writing
enough right now
and what i'll do is i'll do a ton of
shows to torture myself
like i'm like well i'm not writing
enough so you could have to say the same
jokes over and over again
or you have to write a new [ __ ] joke
a little bit but it's it is getting
painful i gotta really start i gotta
turn on the heat a little bit
yeah but if the ideas aren't there
sometimes that faucet is not going and
then sometimes you get this creative
flood of jokes and ideas so yeah it's
all it's a natural thing it's like it's
ups and downs but
that's good that you know yourself well
enough that if you tell the same jokes
it'll force you to pump something out
you know be really cool on this podcast
if we got to a point where we had like a
professional bartender in-house
oh how cool would that be just like a
dude and a bow tie who's just hanging
back there yeah
yeah can he be shirtless is that is that
better or worse
i think shirtless with suspenders in a
bowtie i'm in that'd be badass yeah yeah
uh patrice had that thing where he had a
great joke he's like i don't
i don't want to be alone but i want to
be my myself
wow and you're like oh he just said what
i said in a much more
beautiful way so true though wow because
you know you want somebody in your life
but you don't want to talk to them
basically yeah i mean which women will
never understand
they some do some really do because i
think some of the same thing but uh
i also just struggle to connect right
now i'm just not connected
yeah i think like the pandemics played a
role in it i think
you know maybe you shouldn't be though
if you're not feeling connected
just i think that's normal ride the wave
riding away and connect it yeah yeah
unconnect for a while then then you'll
be ready to connect
what if this just turned in like a dark
drinking pocket i'm like i'm just not
[ __ ] there dude i just get [ __ ]
exhausted
i'm so alone thank god you're not one of
those drunks i value my friends
because we all know those drunks who
[Music]
it's like dr jekyll and mystery oh yeah
oh yeah
my gal luckily is a is the funnest drunk
she's smiley even if she's like woozy
she's
like this is great i love it here you
know and uh that's that's nice because
i've dated the girls who just
flip a switch it's almost more important
than the sex
almost what do you mean good drunk oh
yeah be dating a good drunk
for boozy guys like us yeah yeah yeah
what what
you've probably had girlfriends that
didn't drink or not alive
i have and i've also had ones where
it's a problem yeah i've also had ones
where i'm like oh [ __ ] this is like i'm
pulling hair back
oh yeah well sometimes that turns them
on
but yeah i know what you mean and then
you're just fighting at 5am and then she
wakes up at 11 and she's like
what happened last night like what are
you kidding you told me i had a tiny
dick and you [ __ ] my brother
and yeah you're lesbian now yeah
that was the worst
those are tough times i had a gal who
was such a bad drunk
i would debate i was so poor and that
was a young comic but i would debate
getting a hotel
what like if she went out drinking i was
i was i thought about getting a hotel
that's how terrifying she was as a drunk
i remember i dated a girl
and it was her birthday and we weren't
dating that long i was like we were only
dating a few weeks
and she got [ __ ] lit up yeah like to
the point that she started vomiting in
the street and i was like
i've been with you like three weeks and
i have to take care like this is a bad
start yeah that's a flag that's a real
flag
damn that's tough did it last no it was
like two more weeks probably
yeah i can't believe i gave it two more
weeks it sucks as a guy though because
you can't really get out that easy you
know i feel like if a guy
is a crazy drunk a girl can be like i'm
nervous around you what if you hit me
but as a guy you're like ah i'm just
sick of you puking
it doesn't sound as as you're right it's
just like you be
they're not there so if someone has a
drinking problem they just it's guy or
girl someone's a real drinking problem
yeah
they don't know right they just don't
know how bad [ __ ] is
remember when they when hasselhoff went
viral
oh with the hamburger yeah and it's like
you're like this is it by the way it
wasn't even that bad it was just like
drunkenly eating a hamburger
which like i've done way worse i did
that saturday yeah you get the leftovers
open
if you're a former star who is like
shirtless on a show that is rock bottom
oh completely you had carbs yeah
you're disgusting it's funny mel gibson
watches his
meltdown he's like i would kill to be
hassle off i would kill for that
meltdown
well yeah you have to videotape him i
guess it's just
uh yeah pat o'brien had a legendary one
too
oh access hollywood yeah what'd he do
again he just went off on everything and
he called his wife a [ __ ] and all this
[ __ ] and it was
wild i mean he it was almost poetic how
good with words he was
it's funny when people who are public
speakers get lit up i remember i did a
gig
uh i did a gig for uh it was like a gig
for the new york rangers once
and it was like a trump golf course i
don't like it was a weird gig wow
yeah i just got in the cat i didn't know
where i was going i got in the car
that's how that's how little i read
itineraries
yeah i'm like where am i going like
westchester i'm like
all right so i start i start uh i go
on and there's a pretty famous sports
caster there and he and
and i say to mama i'm a he reeks of
scotch yeah
hammered and i'm not gonna say it was
but he was reeking of booze and i said
oh i'm a big fan of your work who was he
said why i haven't seen your work so my
opinion of you remains to be seen
geez and it was like such a it was so
well though everything he said to me was
so cutting but he was clearly [ __ ] house
wasted
right right but he's still eloquent yeah
that was a bad gig oh my god
i bombed hard dude yeah i bombed for
just like rangers legends it sucked
damn and then and then adam graves came
up to me who uh
was one of my favorite players growing
up i loved that rangers team with like
adam graves and messier and
all those guys and adam graves walks up
to me and he was just searching for
something positive to say but he
couldn't find it and he goes
i love humor that's all he could give me
i love
humor oh man brutal did you take his
shirt over his head and start wailing
man that's tough yeah so many bad gigs
so many uh
i didn't know you were a rangers guy i
didn't know you were a hockey guy i was
a bigger fan when i was a kid now it's
like i'm just too into basketball that
like
and that's like how much can i be into
at this point exactly if someone if
there's like a big guy
my friends my friends who are big fans
so if they're like you got to watch this
game with me i'll watch it but
i mean i'm so into the nba i like to
watch movies i like yeah i like to do
stand-up i like to do other stuff
we got a lot of interests we got a lot
of interest what uh what's up with the
islanders i feel like they're kind of
the black sheep
of uh new york hockey yeah i never it
was weird i think they're good
i don't know i don't know enough about
hockey honestly i think uh but
i never got you never hear about them
it's always rangers rangers
harry they're good now though aren't
they even the devils you hear about
no you know the devils were devils were
killers yeah and they were
uh brodora was a [ __ ] killer yeah i
loved i loved hockey growing up because
i mean the rangers were awesome they had
messier i mean that was like the most
crazy that was that would have been the
best sports year in new york history
rangers and knicks winning and the
knicks lost in game seven but
the rangers were down and mark messier
the captain said i guarantee you win and
they won
wow it was pretty badass just guarantee
it
yeah that's some [ __ ] hardcore and
they won and they won
man that's crazy that team was badass
for sure
a friend of mine banged a new york
ranger whoa say what friend or what
ranger
but she said uh biggest biggest dong
she's ever seen in her life
yeah hockey players are the nicest
people they're nice they're tough
i like hockey players they seem uh they
seem more
normal i don't i feel like if i met i
don't know brett favre if he'd be like
he'd be kind of a [ __ ] to me but i feel
like a hockey guy i could go drinking
with
yeah probably although brett favre was
in something about mary which is pretty
dude
what a cameo what a cameo what a movie
brett favre
yes yes they don't like comedies like
that anymore
i mean that was politically incorrect
then then
but you know what i rewatched it
recently it holds up oh
still great still great that's me matt
dylan
matt dillon steals a movie i mean when
he gets everyone's grading it there's
pants
yes pants are undone rice cerrone the
san francisco treat uh these [ __ ]
you're changing their image
yeah this guy had a drive-in theater for
a move
for a forehead i mean that scene dude i
was
i was a howling i showed that over to
someone who was like
what what exactly the the [ __ ]
people oh man that was amazing
matt dillon was gold lee evans dude oh
you two should be kissing my hairy
[ __ ] bean bag
man that was great chris elliott harlan
williams
mary i love her man
yeah yeah you ever had a white head on
your eyeball i know that movie like the
back of my ass that's one of my favorite
is that your favorite fairly brothers oh
yeah oh yeah okay
take it over dumb and dumb i do i just
like it better dumb and dumber's great
but it's way
sillier this is just jokes i love them
dumb and dumber's amazing i mean
it's a it's a symphony it's a it's a
masterpiece people that don't find that
funny i feel like bad i feel bad for
them
i've shown that movie to people who
don't get it and they're just like i
don't know
multiple people they're like yeah it's
not for me they think they're at some
elitist [ __ ] like oh this is beneath
me this is slapstick [ __ ] i'm like now
this is brilliant
this is like beyond this is comedy
concentrated jeff daniels didn't really
do that many comedies but he's so good
in it
so good he can kill him no comedies
really
yeah yeah i guess you're right pretty
ballsy to go up against that
force of jim carrey too and he he held
his own he didn't even go up
they were just like they just i think
sometimes when you get a guy that good
in his prime
yeah you almost just he just makes you
look better because get caught
true they were both so [ __ ] perfect
so good so good but she was so hot what
was her name oh lauren holly
holy [ __ ] whatever happened to her i
don't know she was
she was one fine piece of ace
quite the redhead yeah yeah no she was
really hot
but why are these uh these dramatic
queefs these uh these jeff dale who's
great
but i think jim carrey might be more
talented because i think comedy's harder
yeah i don't they're both great i think
like you know
jeff daniels is such a good dramatic
actor he's amazing in that i mean just
to show they both have those gears like
jim carrey
he's a good dramatic actor too that's
true but uh
and seinfeld once said greg kinnear used
to do stand-up comedy
then he went into acting and won an
oscar but he quit comedy
which says a lot will ferrell can't do
stand-up but he's he's a brilliant
comedic actor michael keaton
yeah stand-up's hard he was good though
i heard he was pretty good yeah i saw a
youtube thing he was funny
very likable yeah likability
goes a long way some for some reason
goes too long see i'm not likable so
have to really win shut up with zinc
shut the [ __ ] up you're not likable
you get me but uh grandma you know
you're not likable
when you're like doing a pedophile joke
in toledo
you're not what are you talking about by
the way i [ __ ] on dayton earlier i
actually like dayton ohio i should have
said toledo toledo sucks
dayton is actually kind of there next
month yeah
oh yeah funny bones well i'm taking all
the toughs i'm doing syracuse again i'm
doing toledo
i'm doing a bunch of bats i'll a razor
blade
jesus i know i just want to get my set i
feel like you got to run it through the
mud a little bit
because it's it's doing well as a
45-minute chunk
but you got to see what's too too cool
for school too smart for the room
whatever it is you're smart you and
you're brave i i i mean look i just got
an albany offer and i was thinking about
it i don't know
i'm doing albany too you're not gonna do
it i'll probably i'm
filling up here i'm filling up and i
kind of just have to make choices i want
to make sure i can hit like cities like
chicago and sf and san diego this year
and i if i take every city i can't hit
you know cities i i really want to hit
that's true but i do yeah
i i i do want to hit albany but i just
[ __ ] i think i'll just sell better than
those others
so we are brought to you by manscape the
best in below the bell grooming
precision tools for your family jewels
don't use the same trimmer that you use
to shave your face as your balls
i've done it it tastes terrible get
manscaped
they're simply obsessed with keeping
your balls safe and clean manscape trust
me over 2 million men worldwide that's 4
million bowls
in case unless some of them have had
testicular cancer i don't know
manscapes trusted by a lot of men guys
and we have an exclusive offer for our
listeners 20
off and free shipping with this code
drunk at manscape.com
riff oh riff on manscape
sorry i'm drunk we've been drinking we
might not you gotta get the perfect
package manscape hooks you up with a
bunch of
tools and formula they do have a lot of
cool stuff they give you the trimmers
they give you the
the ball toner they give you the it
makes your balls smell better it's nice
the wipes the the wipes and the
lawnmower this is their third
generation trimmer i've used it it makes
your balls look nice and uh
neat yes makes your dick look bigger too
you got that right
has a cutting edge ceramic blade to
reduce grooming accidents thanks to
their advanced
skin safe technology it also comes with
led light
and a more precise shave and is
waterproof shaving the shower
mark tell them about the rest man i love
manscape you got to do it i throw the
lawnmower in on my suitcase on the road
i just keep it in there the battery
lasts forever
it's a great trimmer it's perfect it's
lightweight it's easy
uh join the scissor bros family with
manscape get 20
off and free shipping with code drunk
at manscaped.com that's 20 off with free
shipping at manscape.com
and use code drunk unlock your
confidence
and always use the right tools for the
job
with manscaped make your dong look
bigger trim the hedges
get after it folks i use it on my face
too
manscape.com 20 off with
freeshippingmanscape.com and use the
code drunk
unlock your confidence guys get in there
here here all right give me the top five
cities
for touring for you i'm talking your
favorite city
club a whole amount of tough
all right i got to put chicago in there
love chicago chicago the crowds are
awesome
they're you know what they combine like
blue collar but also with like
city life which i kind of yeah yeah it's
midwest but they're city people
i love that i can't i i love going to sf
i know they
[ __ ] up the homeless situation yeah
they've really
it is [ __ ] weird you see like a like
a dude with a shaved
like a white guy with a shaved head
flying on a hoverboard and then there's
a homeless guy and you're like
you guys should have equalized right
right it's complete extremes
it's [ __ ] on the sidewalk and then
elon musk you know
like is that john luke picard and a
[ __ ] hobo what the hell
uh yeah it's rough uh i like those two
cities for sure
i it's it's tough not to say philly and
boston too
ah yeah i love philly lo i love boston
too but philly i had something about
that city
that club helium is mad great club it's
magical i talked to him today
it's a great club grossman yeah yeah but
how can i not say comedy on state ah
madison with wisconsin man the only
thing i'll say about madison
great probably one of the top three
clubs in the country check it out if you
live there
i wouldn't call it a city that's more of
a town to me i know it's the capital but
but it's small but they got that big ass
farmers market they got that uh veterans
museum it's kind of special that's true
also i will say i would love to say
denver but i've gotten so little love
from that club there really
i've been there once and it was in the
suburbs i i it's like i think it's one
of the best clubs ever
i want to play i'd love to play them
more but like i haven't been there
enough
whereas like yeah those might be my
i had always had a great time in dc big
cities pack it out
and then there's some like weird small
cities that i just happen to love
yeah like all right you can't you can't
say bloomington comedy attic isn't like
a [ __ ] great club
great club and in town yeah cute college
town university indiana
you ever done the uh la jolla comedy
store
magic magic magic and that is it's like
that town seems fake
it's right over the water san diego
rules yeah
yeah you got to put there them in there
too san diego
san diego [ __ ] yeah
they really do they're a great city
great yeah it's trying to hit me now
it's like la weather without the
pretension without the [ __ ] without
the hollywood
actor [ __ ] it's just great people
and the sunshine and the blondes it's
it's got everything
they party too well said yeah it's la
without showbiz talk 24 7. yes
yes there's no producers in san diego
man it's a great city though and that
club that club's got so much history
like it's letterman on the wall and
robin williams and all these you know
[ __ ] leno it's just oh man those
walls shake
well give me yours well i mean you you
covered all the good ones
let me try to think of some uh i mean
austin is awesome austin texas is
awesome just did austin
we did the paramount it was one of the
highlights saying that you did that by
the way well
it's a capacity thing but don't but yeah
but take the [ __ ] w
man i'll take a dub uh but yeah that
austin i love austin's magical but
austin's like
hacked now to say because it's you know
everybody's moving
yeah but i've had great times there i um
hmm
i like houston too yeah houston's
amazing houston
i've only been there once though i did
one night there so i mean i had a great
time but
i opened for a z's in like a [ __ ]
arena
wow it was like 9 000 people or
something was huge
you know it's an underrated club and i i
don't know i hope we're not getting too
uh
uh inside we'll get out and we'll do
people in a minute all right
stick around if we're too nerdy for you
[ __ ] last club i want to give a
shout out to because you named
probably the best ones but i gotta say
royal oak is a sleeper
i'm there in august i go there every
year i love first off
warlock michigan beautiful suburb it
really is dude it's 30 minutes outside
detroit
yeah you know there's like all these
like indie movie theaters there like
where they play
mozart they're playing like who framed
roger rabbit i was like hell yeah dude
that's great i love it um yeah they're
good people at the club i can't wait to
go back always love it
and another quick shout out uh blue room
oh wow in the ozarks it's in uh
columbia missouri i think it's no it's
not columbus i did a club in
in columbia missouri once and holy [ __ ]
they paid me [ __ ]
i [ __ ] had to fight every show it's
not there anymore it was like a club on
top
a [ __ ] dance club on the on the other
floor
and and i think my opener was what are
you doing in the basement my taxes
wait this isn't grand rapids is it no
columbia missouri
hmm i don't know that's the bob i've
been there too of course i've been in
the grand rapids but yeah
they've got the best coffee in the
country at uh madcap
madcap best shout out to a boy phil
hanley's
sends he would send me madcap coffee and
i got me a great mug from there i
usually i use it every day
you know the best coffee in the country
great coffee great
great setup over there uh also i gotta
shout out
salt lake city oh dude i'm there next
month i can't wait that's a [ __ ]
great room great room keith you're the
man great
chicks and those women holy [ __ ] every
guy there looks like an out of work
mma fighter they're all ripped they're
covered in tats because they're sober so
they just work out and
and you know do caffeine same with
sacramento i'm like is this dude gonna
put me in a rear naked choke i'm doing a
[ __ ] meet and greet
i know every guy looks like an mma and
every chick looks like a retired porn
star
you know they're all popped up with the
lips and everything
it's weird whenever people are sober
they always have to go hard into some
other thing
you know they have to go into working
out or or an addict
it's an addict yeah yeah that's why you
know
level yourself out with a little
cocktail which is all absurd
anyway anyway yeah great club
give me a peeve dude all right i got a
couple a couple of hot ones here
oh i like a hot peeve all right uh
okay i had this one in miami and it
[ __ ] drove me up the wall
out of the restaurant nice place with
the lady
i get the we do all the whole thing the
drinks the food the
entree everything's great then the
waitress comes up and i go can i get the
check she goes sure
pulls out the weird uh you know those
new kind of
swipey things that's handheld see if
they do in front of her
gotta do it in front of her and i go you
know what i've been selling merch all
weekend so i got this big
[ __ ] miami cuban wada cash in my
pocket that i gotta get rid of it's
burning a hole in my
ass so i go oh let me just pay cash
what's the bill
okay the bill was 50. so you do the math
okay
20 is 10 so i go all right i'll just
give her 320
60 bucks and she's just waiting there
and i was like what's the bill she goes
it's
50. she shows me the screen and i go
okay
i'll pay in cash she goes great and she
just stands there
i don't want you watching me tip you
it's very awkward then i put 320s down
she took it and left i was like
no no no watch i think if you're a good
tipper this isn't the problem
i know but i don't like the idea of it
because now i'm forced to tip
i mean i was going to anyway but it's
like you always tip i know but i don't
like the uh the stare down it's very
aggressive
like you know when you you print out the
thing you got a tip in front of there's
waiting i'm like
one of your first peeves i'm not sure if
i'm on board with it i don't like the
stairs
i'm on board with all your beams the
tipping is very personal it's very
intimate this isn't the good the bad and
the ugly here this is
i don't like it get out of here sister
let me tip on my own time
if i want to leave a loogie or a phone
number or or whatever it is a condom
this is my time to tip it it's intimate
it's it's vulnerable
right i don't care for because now it's
forced
it's very forced i don't like forced huh
even my girls like i look good today
don't you think i'm like whoa whoa whoa
you can't just force a compliment i
don't want anything i want to
compliment you when i when i believe it
and see it
don't push it can't stand the stand by
me with the tip don't watch me tip
i feel like a lot of tips are standby
tips though if you're at like a coffee
shop when you tip
is it because that's a volunt uh
volunteer tip or what
well that's different yeah that's a
bucket or how about okay how about a
taxi cab that's a
you know they know how much you tip yeah
that's true that's true
but at least i can i got the partition
he's looking the other way i can kind of
dilly dally down here this is just a
lady staring at me watching me count
money
hate it it makes me want to tip less
huh yeah i don't know if i'm on board
with this one i i
totally get it but i also just like i
just
i you probably tip well everywhere so
it's i don't think she's probably just
like thank you right i'm a solid tipper
yeah but i i don't
it feels very like i'm gonna watch and
see how you do
like oh okay now i hear a little tip
intimidation
tip intimidation and she can shame me to
my face which
look i'm a solid tipper but i don't like
the implication if someone's
i'm i'm a [ __ ] i'm spineless so i feel
like even if they're bad i usually
i'm the same way same way so i but i
there are times yeah and i i feel like
i'm fine with this i'm okay i'm okay
with the standby tipping
all right i don't care for it i i i hear
you i got i got a hard one for you
all right hit me go to get an egg
sandwich at my corner store
almost every day to the point though
where the guy goes he goes the usual
and i say yeah and it's a good feeling i
love the usual a toast to the usual
yeah here here to a sandwich place where
they say
the he goes the usual amigo and it feels
like
i feel warmth in my heart i like it he
makes it ethnic yeah he
is ethnic but he also says the usual my
friend
it's a nice feeling so i get now i get
the familiarity
i get the sandwich made the same way i
want every day i get it every day
and here's what happened today i go in
there
i get cut off by a guy i beat him there
but he kind of cut me off
oh i don't like that it's not just it's
like a grocery store but they do
sandwiches
yeah but i go there every day and he
cuts me off so i'm a little annoyed
like maybe he's just shopping for
groceries he cuts me in line for the
sandwich
ah not the usual he didn't know yeah
that's the usual well he didn't order
the usual okay okay what he did was he
goes in front of me
cuts me off and then takes his time
doesn't know what he wants oh
that's a problem that's you wanted to
win so badly
you forgot the rules of the game yes
exactly
good point you better be ready if you're
cutting you got to be ready if you're
cutting i'm annoyed but be [ __ ] ready
yeah that's what you know what that's
like and this is an inside again but
when you
when you go to a show and a guy goes i
gotta get out of here can i go on early
and you go
okay sure and then they go on and they
hang out i hate that
the hang the hang it's a [ __ ] movie
like i got to go first and then
yep have some respect at least hide
outside you know smoke a cigarette but
don't just
say you gotta go and then hang out all
night i hate that
i got another peeve and this one uh
maybe i'll redeem myself but i stand by
the check thing
i've never never not been on board with
your peeves i relate to
i i appreciate it you got me a little
bit with the tip intimidation the idea
that like she's there
of course it's intimidation yeah i used
to move furniture and i always hated
when the people whose furniture you were
moving watched you
oh i did it a couple times i don't have
the frame i just like
i know i'm too lanky i don't use my body
right ah
i can see that i don't have legs i yeah
i don't use my
i'm [ __ ] i'm too light for my frame
i see i need to put some poundage on
what do you think you're let me don't
tell me 185
yeah about all right i'm six three so
yeah that's tall
that's tall uh actually i should be like
195 probably
ah you're fine you're fine yeah you're
lean god is good
yes praise allah but okay so
driving all over miami i don't know
where i'm going i got a rental car you
know and the lady
the trade-off office i drive you you
navigate i think that's fair
that's fair all right so she is younger
than me she's another gen
z or whatever the [ __ ] you want to call
it so she's texting all day so i'm like
okay what's the next move and she's like
oh hold on let me pull the app back i'm
like i shouldn't have to ask
every time i'm like what's next so we
take a right here jesus thank god i
asked the right's right there
why what's next all right in two miles
you take a left
where hold on let me check again i'm
like this is brutal i i shouldn't be
bothering you to get the directions so
that was a pet peeve that's rough
because you guys are a couple you're
supposed to be a team
i'm all in on this one she couldn't stop
texting long enough to keep going with
her
so i had to be like where now that we
missed a few exits i mean it was a
nightmare that's not fair because you're
doing
yeah that's you're not texting right
right i'm driving i was drinking
but uh yeah it was blowing lines off the
dashboard but other than that
no that's that is i'm with you on that
one for sure well also it took us like
an extra 15 minutes because i was like
oh now i got to get back off the highway
then back on the other way like we
missed a bunch of exits it was a
nightmare so just
stick to the plan and keep
keep reading the jesus i'm a terrible
driver so i try to be a good front seat
passenger that's my trade-off i know i
can't drive
i'll come i'll come in hot with some
good mixes i'll give you any type of mix
too i'll [ __ ] go
old school bobby daron louis armstrong
i'll go with some
you know feel good earth wind and fire
bring it up [ __ ]
you make me feel like dancing i'll put
on fun music
i'll go low-key for the end of the night
a little leonard cohen maybe you need
some energy let's put on something crazy
let's put on you know rap whatever you
want i'll do whatever you want i'll have
a good time
but i appreciate that i know i'm a very
i fell asleep only once in a car
uh twice with a comic but i've been
doing this a long time that's like
15 years that's pretty good i don't mind
the sleeping as long as i know where i'm
going but if i need you to navigate i
kind of need you no i i try to be a team
player here
yeah yeah exactly and it's not even look
text away i don't give a [ __ ] but like
come on i shouldn't be asking maybe once
it was once i think
all right you're fine i heard about that
by the way
oh no i made it up but we got the name
out of you
but yeah ah shafi come on he's young
he was young yeah yeah and it was it was
for like three minutes it was i just
passed out for like three minutes
uh i'm trying to see if i think i had
another peeve
ooh i got you one i yeah good good for
you for being a team player i don't want
to do any of the raid i'm not a radio
guy
it's too much pressure really so anybody
who wants to do the radio it's the same
with a guy wants to grill
i'll grill i'm like great you thrilled
it does hurt when they hate your taste
well that's that does feel like a
personal attack yeah that's true
well you like you put like work and
thought into a mix and they're like oh
can you change it you're like yeah i
only spent two hours on it no big deal
are you showing up with a cd no but i do
spotify lists
and i have mixes ready to go oh i forgot
about it because we do the road a lot
and i want to make sure we have good
music ready to go
yes that's very thoughtful i'll do jazz
i i like jazz because that way we can
have a conversation but
if we don't talk it's not weird yeah
exactly exactly i like a little jazz
a little up tempo yes good call
you know what maybe that's my wreck this
week i got a good wreck jazz if you
don't listen to
oscar peterson maybe my favorite uh
pianist ever man
really incredible yeah i don't know
oscar oh you love it
yeah it's great uh oscar peterson
uh yeah that's my wreck for this week
all right anything just put him in a
spotify
one of the best ever so we haven't done
a lot of music on here for
the point you did one week doctor dog
yeah but yeah oscar peterson
guaranteed you will like it if you like
jazz at all
all right i'll throw out dave brubeck
okay i don't know dave ruben yeah he's a
great the 60s
uh jazz guy killer killer take five
is one of his best songs check it out
i'm gonna check it out on the way home
should we do you wanna do a couple
emails yeah hit me uh harry
what should we do remember it's uh we
might be drunk
i got some up here too gmail.com what
should we do a pee of a wreck what do
you want
give me a peeve i'm in a pv mood all
right we got a drink
do we do a drinking peeve or just a
regular peeve
either one either one maybe a regular
this one brian
all right hey guys saw mark in boston a
few years back looking forward to seeing
sans from things open up i'll be in
boston in september can't wait
thank you uh uh love being
love i really do love performing in
boston i love laugh boston
p if saying saying right as a
conversational tick at the wrong time
oh it should be used when there's an
assumption of agreement like when you're
pointing out something
obvious right not when you're telling
someone new information that destroys
the meaning of the word
very very annoying yeah you're like a
literal you're a literal person here
yeah yeah i'm with him on that totally
right
right right right right right
sometimes they'll just say it you know
you're like man my mom's a [ __ ]
right like yeah you're not supposed to
agree with that yeah
exactly right we got a ton of peeves
jesus oh give me a peeve
hey gents always enjoy a good rant so
maybe i can provide a few here this is
from
jeremy well or wheel while
when are you when you are at a
restaurant and someone you are with
asks what's good here what do you expect
the waiter to say
better yet the person then ends up just
ordering a salad or something that the
waiter does not even recommend
also we have the internet at our
fingertips look up the [ __ ] menu
[ __ ]
that's a fair one i think that's a fair
peeve i i definitely
it's annoying too like i've seen people
do that where they're like what's good
here and then they just go with
the exact opposite yeah because
sometimes maybe they're trying to be
healthy and they're just like what's
good here
you know the fried uh macaroni and
cheese rice balls and they're like
i'll have a nicoise salad you're like
why why'd you do that then yes
yes i've done it i've guilty we've all
done it no one's not done it
we've done it because if you want them
to kind of say one thing
that you're looking at well sometimes
it's not crazy because sometimes a place
is known for sure
but it's still kind of it's still kind
of like just [ __ ] get what you want
right well one trick you ever heard of
the law of averages
will give me an example well one trick
is you go what's the most popular thing
ordered
and they go the the the salmon and you
go i'll have that
and then you go why why do you get the
popular thing and they go because
if enough people have tried it hated it
liked it and kept getting it
that means it's probably the best thing
also yeah but also could just be a
generic thing too
like but what if they
yeah i think i don't know yeah i i'm not
a big fan of the uh
that question but i do think uh i i
we've all done it we've all done it
because you get scared you go what do
you have and you're like uh what do you
like here you kind of throw it on them
so it gives you more time
and then you go oh i'm gonna get the
cheeseburger and i go get the steak and
you go cheeseburger
every place is like we're known for a
burger like every place is known for
their burger
what place is it known for a burger it's
a burger it's a burger
if you've got a shitty burger stop
serving it right now this is where i'll
lose you again
i don't get the big burger craze
you didn't lose me if it's a great
burger place
i'm if i'm going to minetta lane yeah
the village i'm getting a burger get the
burger we're going to paul's burger i'll
get a burger
burger's not my go-to order no me too a
lot of guys get the burger i think it's
a little cheaper and then they're not
taking a risk it's a burger with fries
you can't really go wrong
but i don't know like we perform every
night it's hard
it's hard to eat when you're that full
oh it's very it makes you feel very
heavy
that too yeah like i'm not getting that
i'm also getting i'm not getting
linguine with clam sauce before i go on
like there's a reason you get certain
things i
love a burger but i try to go a little
lighter on show nights end of the night
i'll go a little heavier
yeah same but the burger's just too
plain for me i need a little i'm from
new orleans i want some spice i want
some
some diversity and on the plate i like a
veggie a noodle a meat
uh a fruit something how about why can't
you do like pepper jack cheese some like
maybe like a spicy mayo maybe you mix it
up a little bit
ah what so what's like what's your go-to
order
when you're being good and when you're
like i want to i want to treat myself a
little bit
i'm a big comfort food douche i love
like soul food and chicken fried steak
and meatloaf
chicken fries [ __ ] new orleans i love
that [ __ ] i can eat that [ __ ] all day
long i mean it's horrible for you and
it's salty
and but man it is [ __ ] good i mean a
good pot roast
oh come on yeah i like the guy who
wasn't satisfied with steak he's like we
got to take it to another level we need
to
we need to fry steak yes well i'm a big
soup douche
where do you stand on soup i love soup
but no no one loves soup as much as you
you are the
soup i gotta there's that place across
from the cellar i got a crab bisque the
other night was pretty good
i i love a good dude if it's a good soup
i'm [ __ ] in
yeah i love a good soup borscht is my
favorite soup porsche is great but
the seller has hot porsche which is rare
you like cold boys no i like hot but
i i feel like everywhere i go i'm like
oh give me the borscht isn't viselka
isn't it cold
they do both they do both these elk is
good if you're in new york city and
haven't eaten there
support man one of the best ukrainian
diner in the east village
24 hours before this hopefully they get
back together i know one of the best
[ __ ] spots
by the way ukrainian is the most
underrated food everybody talks about
italian and french and mexican and
uh whatever but uh ukrainians like the
pierogies and the dumplings and the
meats it's so good kasha stuffed cabbage
oh the cabbage
you just feel like everything was made
by like an old woman with heavy tits
yes yes a grizzled old lady who's just
worked on a field and got beat by her
husband just a weird apron
and yeah huge cans oh there's another
one
from uh jeremy when you're on an email
text chain with people and they ask a
dumb question that could have been
answered if they just took two seconds
to scroll up
interesting this guy's all about
efficiency and uh you know finding out
i don't get a lot of like work email
things but
i am on text threads and yeah sometimes
you get on one and
and one person is like non-stop and
you're kind of like i don't know
you can tell he's just doing it to like
just interact he wants to keep it going
like come on man
i'm i'm a big fan i just like one on one
yeah
so much i'm down for like a a small hang
but like
as you get older i would think about
when you remember when you're young and
whoever's the party is kind of like you
have to invite everyone or you're an
[ __ ]
like you're either inviting everyone or
you're ignoring a bunch of people that
you ignore ignore and then you get older
and it's like the
cause there's not a lot of places to
drink when you're young sure if there's
a place to drink and it's good
literally everyone finds out about it
yeah uh uh bobby's texting me can bobby
come
yeah yeah all right bobby can then it
turns into like 400 people
right on one little [ __ ] roof that's
how it goes but then you're older and
it's like small it's just
better older uh you know it's better it
really thirties are great man
people like 20s and i miss my my college
years like wow
30s is the way i mean 40 i'm i'm sure as
hell because that's kids and stuff but
30s is the best decade i'm loving it man
loving it you're an adult but you're
still young
you still get it up you're not too fat
yet you got some hair
still and you like you know how to [ __ ]
now and you know how to drink
way better yeah it's all downhill from
here though oh where we're going a hell
of a handbasket
but yeah that's fair should we do
another peeve yeah i like
for some reason i like the peeves peeves
have kind of they're very relatable you
do racks too though
i had a uh a nightmare the other day
that had that i had an office job
yeah what job was it i had a nightmare
last night too
actually it was clerical just like i was
typing and i was wearing a tie
and i was in a cubicle and i was like oh
man i hate this job they were like
where's the files where's the files like
ah
i was like this is my nightmare and it
brought me back because i've done all
those jobs
you ever ever like have a job job it was
all like part-time [ __ ]
yeah nightmare yeah i never did like a
real
nine-to-five office job isn't that i
mean we take for granted like obviously
we know we're lucky and comedy's awesome
but
the idea of a boss saying like you gotta
you gotta stay a couple extra hours
tonight like
oh my god i can't even fathom it anymore
i'm i'm [ __ ] grateful every day man i
i love what we do like i i i do to even
when i have a bad night i'm like i love
stand up somewhere yeah this last year
has been hell like it really has been
like oh yeah it's been hell i missed it
so much like i was doing [ __ ]
rooftops every night man
yeah i was like i can't it felt like
going back in time
it was weird because i had like when i
started i didn't have people that would
come out and see me so
you know there was that but now i was
kind of like well people were willing to
come see me places
yeah but they were shitty places right
so i'm kind of like i'd get them on
roofs
and wherever we'd go but uh but you know
what's cool about what you did you put
out the rooftop special
and people came and saw you a lot
you get a lot of roofs and a lot of sets
and they get to watch that youtube and
go we saw this guy
that was my roof that's pretty cool i'm
filming something at the cellar right
now just like i like capturing this
moment in time yeah something very
special like the first night i went back
and did stand up
seinfeld had like tears in his eyes when
he got off wow there's something heavy
about comedy coming back and just
everything coming back i feel for
broadway actors i feel for
people who who lost everything
restaurant people
you know that's their dream that's their
job i i totally
i i can't imagine so uh
yeah i think of those roofs too and i'm
like man it was it was i looked back and
i like i was with salaccus a boy who
gets more name drops in this podcast
than [ __ ] anyone yeah i love it
but you know we were shooting something
the other night and someone like
came up and with his friend on facetime
and he's like i love the rooftop special
so much i'm like this dude directed it
right here
and that's like a cool moment that he
knows that he made something cool like
it
so i hope i hope you know you know
i don't take any of this [ __ ] for
granted even even we have a bad seller
night or
you know there's someone chatting in the
crowd like there was tonight and you're
getting heckled i'm like oh this is the
best [ __ ] ever the best [ __ ] ever i like
the ancillary stuff too i like the hotel
i like the road
i like uh you like the road i kind of do
too i love the road is that weird of us
to like it
probably we're probably [ __ ] up and we
need an escape and we need to be
kind of we i like variety i want to be
in denver one day
and then we fix the next we yes
yes we do that's why we like it because
the road is like it's like all temporary
it's temporary but it's also like
all my [ __ ] let me just put it over here
for a second yeah it's like it's like
cleaning your apartment but you don't
really clean it you just grab everything
and throw it in the closet throw it in
the closet yes that's so true
i'm coming out of the closet finally but
it's so true i like oh i got to go to
denver and then you're in denver you're
like i gotta leave
i love that i love getting in and
getting out you get a taste of it it's
like dating a girl for three days
it's perfect none of the none of the
fights come up yet before they realize
i'm in the dominican republic
yeah yeah like you're in denver you're
like oh
i uh i don't have bills here yet i don't
have to buy an apartment i don't have to
get a job you know just in and out i
love that
i do i remember hearing jon stewart once
on npr he was doing
terry gross and he said like i feel like
a cowboy you know like
like we just go city to city and i was
like man i love the way like great
comics
just romanticize what we do yeah also
jews are dying to be cowboys we're dying
dude
yeah what is it why do we want to be
cowboy so bad i think is it such a
gentile-y thing
closest we got was dustin hoffman
midnight cowboy he died pretty awfully
so
that was that's true but yeah somebody
described to me as paratroopers i
remember one time this is probably three
years ago
i'm texting with you i'm texting with
list i'm texting with macky
all in the same day and you're like i'm
an albany mac he's like i'm in phoenix
joe's like i'm in seattle and i'm like
man i'm in a
akron ohio and we're all just trying to
get laughs and then we're gonna leave
it's such a cool thing we just they need
comedy here they need jokes they need to
laugh here let's go
[ __ ] love it man love it there's a
comic on a plane at all times you know
in the in the country it is hilarious
when you're just sitting there and the
comic just sits right next to you on a
flight and you're like
here we go yeah there's a weird bond you
see a comic in the airport you're like
hey where are you going he's like i'm
going to [ __ ] uh
tampa you're like i'm going to atlanta
oh that's a good club you got the whole
thing you know
yeah you got a bond there i love it man
there's morning i'm like
yeah i'm excited i mean i'm i'm i need
to build a new act so
same uh anything weird these comics who
didn't do anything in the painting i'm
not saying
you should go out and try to do shows
because they weren't really shows but
like
you got to do something we started a
podcast you did the roof thing
i'm i'm doing crazy i know you got a new
[ __ ] hour too
oh [ __ ] you i know you have a new hour
fifteen of it is covet or
ten minutes so it's not that long yeah i
just need a new i feel like i got like
15
20 that i like right now yeah and then
yeah you know and it'll keep i mean on
the road i'll get to try more [ __ ] and
feel it out but
i feel like it'll come more
each day more [ __ ] comes and it's like i
i feel like i
here's the thing what we do we do so
many sets
like i'm doing a few night again like i
used to yeah and
i start to hate my act and i'm like why
do i hate it because i do a lot of sets
but if you get a couple
two or three new jokes a year you got an
hour yes exactly
two three jokes a week a week or a month
yeah
but you got an hour so it just makes you
angry that you don't have more
but when you do a lot of sets i mean
this is our thing a lot of our friends
like they have a show
or something this is kind of all we've
done always yeah that's true
that's true and i like it i like this
gritty kind of weird
salt of the earth nomad lifestyle
and look it gets sad don't get me wrong
there's comics we know and look up to or
like man this guy's like alone and he's
65
and no kids no wife and just grinding it
out still
and i think if you play it right though
you can
be a comic forever like a bill burr is
doing great he's got two kids and a wife
and he's happy he's a millionaire and
he's
respected yeah it's a it's a tough
uh wave to surf but you can pull it off
yeah and well again the 30s
we can still roam a little bit that's
[ __ ] wrong dude hell yeah should i do
another
do another one which one we're getting
we're getting sappy about stand up are
we sappy it's
you know what you guys [ __ ] tune into
a drinking podcast if you're not in it
if you're not into [ __ ] getting weird
every once in a while that's on you i'm
sorry
we popped at the last show this [ __ ]
this tequila is good dude
oh the best this is pretty good
oh we got a name for bourbon how about
road gig ooh i kind of like that that's
not bad
that's not bad i heard another one today
call back
call me like i'll have a call back it
almost sounds like a pickle back or
let me get another call back or road
comic
i do like the old-timey picture of us in
the bottle though yeah that's not bad
we got a wreck have you see it says
fleabag have you seen it
i love it it's a great show amazing show
great show what's her name
phoebe waller there you go yeah she's
excellent
it's funny i found myself becoming more
attracted to her as the show went on
you know why because she's [ __ ]
talented talented but she's
she is pretty also but she is a huge
mole on her forehead
that's why she wears her hair like that
oh really yeah which is probably why
she's funny
everyone's gotta have a thing you gotta
have a thing yeah
all right i gotta i got one from corey
pachette did you did you go
did you read yours i did yeah okay so
you hit corey pachette
said hey mark and sam huge fan of you
both from here in canada don't stop what
you're doing my biggest pet peeve is
when you're walking in any major city
with awnings everywhere while it's
raining
and the [ __ ] with the umbrellas are
walking under the awning
and still don't move when you're trying
to stay under them yourself
get the [ __ ] out of the way and have
some self-awareness you got an umbrella
i need the awning i always love you guys
please uh when life gets back to normal
come to a show here love from canada by
the way where the [ __ ] are you in canada
is huge
i love that come to canada all right i'm
in montreal hi
i live in vancouver well you got to
specify you i'm in a winnipeg
and not that either okay yeah yeah yeah
no it's uh
probably not canada realistically until
next year i don't think
yeah we're gonna get that vaccine
passport yeah
uh-huh some people are pushing against
it we'll see what happens i don't know
i'd love to dude i love toronto so much
i love
love it montreal i don't love doing
stand up there i'll be honest uh
really do have you ever murdered in
montreal
yeah i guess you're right i haven't
they're [ __ ] they're like they don't
laugh
the comedy nest i bomb the festival i do
okay
but those are comedy people i guess yeah
it's tough toronto you'll [ __ ] kill
trump love toronto rules
toronto's got a little uh stank on it
vancouver i do well
vancouver's one of the most beautiful
cities amazing
in the [ __ ] world it's so expensive
but what about winnipeg
i i had a great i've only been to that
club once but i had a great time that's
a good club
man uh that guy tyler's a good guy who
runs that club great guy
i was in uh i was in that condo though i
can't [ __ ] i'm done with condoms oh
[ __ ] done it was years ago and i was
of course i was i knew i was there after
an la guy because there was like almond
milk in the fridge yeah no new york
comic book
i like it but i know new york comedy
didn't buy it yeah so true
that condo is a bummer because it's like
it's a condo
a condominium in this building and it's
it it's also an old folks home
oh really so i'm coming home at 5 00 a.m
with some you know
big lady i'm under one arm and then you
know old man johnson is in the
playing he's playing rummy in the in the
lobby area and i'm like oh hey he's
leaving i'm coming in it was it was a
nightmare
yeah canada vancouver really is
where it's at oh yeah great town that's
seawall
vancouver's like the la equivalent yeah
and i feel like toronto is new york
no doubt about it and it's way more um
like cultural what's so diverse that's
the word
but yeah yeah good good place
saskatchewan's a little scary there's
that one room
what's that room comic strip up the
edmonton
whoo man i heard that's a [ __ ] hell
gig hell gig i mean
they call it these uh rig pigs these
guys who work on rigs all day
oil man yeah yeah they make a fortune
because there's good money in it so they
just buy blow and scotch
and they're like uneducated and they
just yell at you they called me a
[ __ ]
every slur in the book so you gotta it's
just babysitting these rig
pigs how was your show i got called a
[ __ ] i think i don't know
yeah yeah uh i did a gig like that once
in vernal utah it's an oil rig town and
there was a
like the saddest gig they were like we
put you up in the nicest room i get
there i'm like
the honeymoon suite i'm in a [ __ ]
like heart-shaped bed
with a giant jacuzzi i'm like this is
the most depressing [ __ ] i've ever
just put me in a regular room yeah oh
man i did ac once and like we're gonna
give you the sinatra suite i was like
jesus sinatra sweet who the hell am i i
get there was the worst rule i've ever
seen the door came off when i opened it
it was one of those like
everything was like from the 40s like
back in his heyday it was
so dusty and shitty there's a guy in the
other room just hitting a woman you're
like oh this is the synonym
um yeah dude i remember i did ac once
tropicana this [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
ripped me off he never paid me uh right
out it was a week after i recorded it
was
2015 i recorded a half hour for comedy
central and uh
and i'm an ac and it's of course like
you have that friend
who's like a degenerate gambler my
friend adam who's hilarious but he's
he's a degenerate [ __ ] gambler yeah
gamble's on the wnba
like yeah you know you've got a problem
when you've made it to
the w like he
he shows up [ __ ] face just like shows up
he's the type of guy
if i got a casino gig he's just there
yeah right like
you're here he's like yeah it's a casino
i'm like all right and then he's like
come on seattle storm
give it to me wow wnba that's hilarious
gamble's on ever he texts me he's like
you feeling good about the knicks
tonight i'm like
i'm a die hard fan you can't ask me i
don't wanna i don't wanna [ __ ]
i don't want your money on the line on
my name like who you got the spelling
bee
akilah yeah go indian
[Laughter]
but uh yeah man no he but he should i
remember
it was that classic gig you should face
to your [ __ ] hotel room
no wi-fi it wasn't even like a hotel
like a [ __ ] condo on the boardwalk
yeah come and [ __ ] face cockroach cop
stomp and they just pass out drunk and
uh
end of the week they never [ __ ] paid
me damn
yeah brutal man those cause casinos are
hard enough already they just the guy
disappeared he like
he had like a [ __ ] oh dude what a
piece of forgot his name but he's a real
piece of dog [ __ ]
ac is a sad sad place it is rough
it's got a good history it's got all
this like lore about it like you know
dean martin
you know went down on a lady here or
whatever it is but he went down a woman
everywhere that's true
yeah that's true yeah but man it is a
bummer everything's like
dingy everything looks like it had a
heyday and then it's
that was 35 40 years ago you ever go to
tony's baltimore grill
and uh ac i don't know it's like an
all-night 24-hour
they serve you order you say i'll have a
jack and coke
they just give it to you in a pint glass
wow and it's like six bucks
it's classic it's old italian women
they're just serving you pasta
too my brother did a bachelor party in
atlantic city
nice and i was like i kind of told off
with hammer i'm like we got to stop in a
tony's baltimore grill
and and everyone was like all right and
we walked in everyone's like this place
is the [ __ ] yeah
it's great when you like wreck a place
hammered and yes yes good call
i do love a shitty dive like that but
also it's funny that baltimore is their
go-to like this is the baltimore
baltimore sucks
baltimore's are [ __ ] down hey we're
going to uh youngstown inn
we're going to the chernobyl dive
yeah we got a darfur cafe coming up
we're going to get a lot of letters for
this one i started with [ __ ] uh
dominican republic and i
we went downhill from there oh we did
albany we did syracuse we did toledo
and now uh baltimore we're [ __ ] but
[ __ ] down and you you guys left too
don't give me [ __ ] every time i go there
it's nothing but white flight
oh we got to do a bit you want to do a
bit yeah
i got you let me go first yeah please so
this is one
i don't know there's i think there's
more meat in this bone i hit tonight i
think there's something here
but i was talking to my friend he goes
i'm battling depression and i was like
oh i've never had that
and uh he goes you never know no i've
been depressed but
it's never been a battle right every
time i feel depression coming on i'm
like
you win ah that's fine i spread my
cheeks i'm like do whatever you'd like
depression
you assume the position yeah yeah
there's some i don't know where to go
with it really there's something about
like to me the idea of like
here's what you do when you're depressed
it's not a [ __ ] battle you go
all right i'm gonna wait it out right
i'm gonna i'm gonna watch
another sopranos i'm gonna order
seamless
have some coffee i get mad by the way
when coffee doesn't cure my depression
ah yeah coffee cures everything it cures
that better hangover sleepiness
that's weird that it cures your hangover
because for me it's it gives me a
headache
really i mean i do it because i need to
wake up a little bit but like yeah it's
[ __ ]
it's exciting cure your hangover for me
it actually
oh i crave it i'm like i'm so hungover
i'm like give me a coffee and i'm like
all right
i'm kind of getting back to normal now
it like kicks me into gear
weird but maybe you drink so much coffee
it's probably just you know just
it's normal for you i still get a kick
from coffee
i [ __ ] love a nighttime coffee i'm
glad that i'm working again at night
regularly because you have a night time
like a private eye yeah i had one
tonight at the show i felt great you
feel like you're on law order sv yeah
like what do we got i know like a coffee
at a diner at midnight oh
nothing i'll even get a decaf just for
that look that feel
yeah the taste is nice yeah i think
there's something to the depression
thing
i have a lot of depression ideas i had i
added to it
um there's there's a lot here i think
there is a lie
just about about like how you just give
it it's not not everything's a battle
right sometimes you're just counting the
time to you're not losing anymore
yes yeah it's more like uh it's more
like a headlock or something where you
just gotta like my older brother should
give me a headlock just and watch tv
and i would just get comfortable and he
has to wait it out you know
it's kind of like uh yeah what's
something that just you have to just
wait for it to end like a like when the
power's out you know you're like all
right
kind of like being the dmv yeah like
this sucks
hopefully it'll be over in three hours
exactly exactly yeah
something there yeah yeah then every
picture of you looks terrible
yeah there's something there you
shouldn't be you shouldn't be driving i
don't know
that is interesting it's true it's not a
battle
it always wins and you just have to get
through it but it's
how long it wins yes yes
it's more of a like a
a marathon not a sprint it's like
something that takes long
a long time not really because a battle
can be just quick
and one and you're like we won this one
but this depression is like uh
it's a it's a lifetime battle yeah you
know what it's like it's kind of like
it's like if you were like uh a fighter
but they didn't schedule your fights
oh yeah you're like a boxer and you're
like i thought we were doing this on the
20th and you're like oh [ __ ] let me yeah
yeah it comes out of nowhere yeah all
right yeah
something there i'm gonna play with that
what do you got definitely a lot there
what do you got
damn um maybe it's like being fumigated
just gotta wait it out i don't know all
right
uh i gotta this just tell me this is a
dumb line and i'll get rid of it
so my friend is native american and he
hates
jeep he's like i don't like the cherokee
thing he's like it bothers me
i'm like why it's not like a dig and
he's like i don't like
him using our name and i'm like or not
our name but our
our thing that's i'm a cherokee whatever
and i'm like all right all right well
wait till
caitlyn jenner hears about the trans am
have you done it have you done it yet i
did it in miami and it killed but that's
miami
that's a coke fueled uh you know i don't
think it's bad i kind of don't know
all right all right it's a throwaway i'm
not i'm not uh resting my keys on yeah
yeah yeah
or my coat on it it just just hopes she
doesn't drive it
yeah there you go that's the tag
yeah that's not bad yeah all right she
didn't kill someone right
she did she ran over imagine being
bruised imagine being killed by
caitlyn jenner what a weird
what a weird thing like how'd your
grandma die kaitlyn jenner yeah
i love the guy he gets hit he's like
what the [ __ ] you do dude i mean ma'am
right he's gotta still correct it that
he died
you [ __ ] at [ __ ]
[Laughter]
uh all right so that was just a dumb
throw away and then this is something
i've been working on for
or i've been thinking about for a while
that i need your help on
kids are the opposite of food because
kids well wait sex is the opposite of
food because
food you want to eat right away
but and it has an expiration date you
can't eat it after this but
kids you can [ __ ]
after the expiration you know
food you you eat before i say people
because you can't ever [ __ ] kids
oh yeah good point people people
people you [ __ ] after 17 kids you gotta
wait a few years until they're nine or
ten
uh you know it's like food it's good
right now
yeah and uh once it hits a certain date
the milk is spoiled
but a kid you are a human you want to
[ __ ]
after 18. interesting it's almost like
you gotta wait it's almost like an
avocado
it's not ready yet interesting yeah
avocados it's ready quickly so i don't
know avocados i don't know if that is
either i'm just spitballing here
food has an expiration date must have
bye
food you want you don't eat too late
people you don't want to [ __ ] too early
that's the truth that's the thesis yeah
like people have an expiration date or
wait no you got to jump on food you got
to be patient with people
that's what you're saying there you go
food yeah
yeah you got bananas on the fridge
you're like ah i waited too long
and then mary kate and ashley olsen
you're like oh
it's not time yet avocado
you ever do you ever try to eat an
avocado before it's ready though
it's hard as a rock it's hard as a rock
yeah
no pun intended but uh yeah yeah that's
true avocado is a special
special case because it's like you got
to wait for it
and then it's ruined but too early is
ruined it's like they're ready
that's why i thought about that for the
kid or the person
but uh yeah i think there's something
with that expiration date
you know you check the the milk you're
like oh man i got one more day
and then with a 17 year old you're like
one more day till the birthday
it's clever something's missing though
something's missing
something's missing call in if you if
you can think of it no there's something
about
what this is a love line with sam and
mark it needs
there's an element that i'm i'm missing
here there's something about
maybe someone with like dating apps it's
almost like fresh direct
but like tinder huh maybe there's
something with old people like some
people are too old
to [ __ ] and that's like rotten fruit
your pussy's like a bad mango girl
uh yeah there's something about
it's a chin scratcher wait waiting too
long is also a problem
right yeah there's a sweet spot
you know maybe it's just maybe it's just
like you maybe the bit is just like
the person in their prime 30s is the
prime
yeah for everybody i think the 30s is
the prime right right and
food i mean it's the same with food a
banana's too ripe then a banana is brown
but there's a prime
although i don't know maybe the third
[ __ ] some people hit their prime
later
that's true too but there's still a
midsection that's the
that's the meat of it this is tricky
maybe an old [ __ ] old lady is kind of
like when you reheat leftovers
you know you get some animation back in
it it was like big ziti right there that
was great
yeah that was your name
johnson yeah there's something about
when something goes bad yeah
maybe maybe it's a better maybe you got
to make it like a relationship going bad
maybe that's the way to connect at all
because if it's a relationship going bad
you're like
[ __ ] i i should have done this when i
still could
right right that way it's not about the
looks and it's more about just like a
general
like oh [ __ ] i could have [ __ ]
yeah it's a tough one you're i think
you're right though i think there's an
element missing well if it's a failing
relationship you're like man
this was the last day i could have done
this yeah now it's
it's turned now it's turned the
relationship
yeah yeah that's not bad all right
it's a clever observation i know what
the connection is though i know it's a
tough one
there's some guy right now screaming at
his computer you [ __ ] idiot it's
about
pomegranates yeah yeah
maybe someone planting your seed yeah i
don't know but uh i think there's
something there and
something maybe ah it'd be nice if
people had their
their date just pushed on them so you
could look at it
like in their skin it was like a tattoo
like oh wow she's ready
ooh interesting yeah maybe it's go bad
like
[ __ ] i wish like she's gonna go nuts or
something
oh yeah yeah must [ __ ] her before this
date or she'll get
she'll get attached right right
all right hey that's good stuff that's
something write in
tell us what you think emailed i love i
lost
her and my honey maple on the same day
i took her cherry all right uh yeah
email us
see us on the road i'm gonna be in uh
i'll be in cleveland
uh april 30th through may 2nd next week
and i'll be in uh
spokane and seattle then lancaster the
next weekend in uh
what's in lancaster i don't even know
about that it's a one-nighter but i
can't wait
and then uh pennsylvania then the next
week i'll be in uh
and then i think it's uh utah i'm gone
every week so uh it's all right
every week so you can come see me and
see mark where you gonna be man
also tacoma speaking of baltimore sorry
i trashed the town i'll be in timonium
uh
next week and magooby's yeah hartford
funny bone i'm telling you i'm doing all
the tough ones virginia beach you ever
done that
never never done it no i'm gonna get my
ass kicked out there poor i know
somebody's gonna be like you piece of
[ __ ] you did a story about virginia
beach i changed the city for that story
toledo oh boy syracuse uh houston improv
that'll be fun philly helium
buffalo i'm all over the world are you
coming up you're coming up nice though
after that though yeah
breya that's right i actually got
atlantic city coming up
i'm sorry west palm oh i got arlington
drafthouse last weekend of uh
of may that's a fun one that'll that'll
sell out so you better [ __ ] get on
that [ __ ] you know i had a show already
i can't wait
rhode island providence comedy
connection richmond
laughs you are going hard yeah it's
gonna be a
tough year but we'll we're gonna really
craft that that hour we need another
special
i can't wait oh i got tampa in june i
can't wait i got
raleigh in june again
um we got yeah a lot of good [ __ ] coming
up
i can't wait okay see man this is going
to be great
july levittown new york long island
i took a pic this guy's heckling me the
whole [ __ ] show
tonight and i said where your friend
goes long island i said i'll be there in
july let me take a picture of you we're
going to have a
we're going to have a do not allow for
my show
click there you go folks don't heckle
unless you want to get
dusted and then we'll film it and put it
on the internet i pummeled this
[ __ ]
good i did not care for him
no make sure to email us we not we might
be drunk pod at gmail.com subscribe
leave us a review you know we don't
really plug that but you should leave us
with
you yeah and uh yeah subscribe
yeah we got specials on youtube uh all
kinds of stuff so yeah come see us live
say hello we gotta get some merch we're
still working on that
[ __ ] rye or bourbon or whatnot we
gotta
follow up on that [ __ ] yeah good idea
let's do that give us some names we're
still
call back road gig we got fun ones late
show
late shift we're still we're noodling
folks
so tell a friend spread the love spread
your cheeks
and queef it up comedy
bye-bye